vous en dit toujours avec votre papa
7 jugeant compliqué avec lui c'est comme
un ciel breton il fait beau plusieurs
fois par jour l'église est président de
la république ce que vous pensez est-ce
que vous pensez que si vous êtes
présidente de la république il sera
heureux ou bien oui je suis convaincu
qu'ils s'amendent heureux oui oui parce
que c'est un patriote convaincu qui
s'est battu toute sa vie et malgré les
divergences qu'on a pu avoir
évidemment il se réjouira de voir que la
france offre la possibilité justement de
rompre avec des politiques qui ont été
particulièrement nocive dans les 30
dernières années parce qu'après tout
emmanuel macron n'a été qu'une
continuité des politiques qui avait été
menée avant lui donc l'idée c'est de
refermer en réalité une parenthèse qui a
été une parenthèse qui a dans tous les
domaines affaibli d'autre pays alors que
c'est un grand pays qui a des atouts
absolument insensé mais qui est un qui a
été laissé en fait par nos dirigeants à
peu en jachère on a l'impression que
voilà vous avez rebaptisé le front
national rassemblement national c'est
vrai que votre papa vous l'avez vous
l'avait écarté parce que c'est vrai que
vous êtes dit c'est peut-être un c'est
peut-être un handicap pour moi dans dans
ma compagne dont il
contestait absolument l'intégralité des
décisions que je prenais quoi gérer un
moment donné c'est une tragédie grecque
j'ai réfléchi cent fois je me suis sans
foi est ce que j'aurais pu faire
autrement comment ça c est ce que il y
aurait pu y avoir une autre issue est en
réalité à chaque fois que mon esprit
prenez un chemin on arrivait toujours à
cette rupture comment je pense qu'elle
est écrite c'est quand vous êtes dit les
choses c'est vous qui vous l'avez dit
bon ça a été très douloureux ça a été
douloureux pour moi parce que je laime
c'est mon père et puis ça a été après
tout quelqu'un pour qui je me suis battu
politiquement je me suis battu pour
qu'il soit élu nuit à l'époque je
pensais pas du tout un jour être
candidate à la présidentielle des bonnes
soeurs pas inquiété non non l'époque
n'est rien en train d'hésiter à notre
esprit il serait candidat femme
l'éternelle s'est dit lui même qui
mortels mairie voulait pas parler avait
fini par le croire et parler
politiquement il était morte aller
quelque part il
il aime quand je vois les jeunes qui
parlent de lui
aujourd'hui une forme de une sorte de
totem quand même politique vous ne
pouvez pas parler depuis combien de
temps je lui ai pas parlé depuis trois
semaines à moi vous parlez quand même -
oui oui on se parle et vous donne des
petits conseils oui
ils essayent mais vous les suivez jamais
oui mais vous savez j'ai la tête dure
après tout les chiens ne font pas des
chats non plus un nom